they use the American dream as the
background for family snaps in the place
that's now the Gateway to make it to the
US illegally this is the town they call
way way in Guatemala where they know the
desperation to reach that Promised Land
is leaving their children as the victims
because this is the reality detention
centers in the US overflowing with
50,000 children who've crossed the
border alone since September Barack
Obama has called it a humanitarian
crisis protests across the country call
for an answer but back in Guatemala the
next wave is ready yeah Shawn and Brian
say they'll pay a people smuggler a
coyote thousands so they can join their
brother in the US this year
I'm always gory about what we happen on
the way from here to the border I'm
always saying God will protect me Jorge
was deported from the US he shows us the
world of the coyote he knows why the
young want to go no money to survive he
looking for a new life you know the
poverty and violence in places like this
in Guatemala has always driven people to
seek that better life in the north but
what's happened recently is a rumor that
has swept the country that there's an
amnesty for children who make it to
America on their own the problem is that
room is not true and those who do make
it are simply turned around and sent
back to where they came from
oh you do harm Arne okay you got this
santanico nose last attempt to reach the
u.s. ended last week robbed at gunpoint
by a Mexican cartel I was crying when I
see a kid like my son it's age how old
are you say seven years I said do you
come alone say yeah my dad is there you
could pick me up I can't live my son
gone there yes okay just go ahead you
know you know serving glory he took his
message to a school when asked how many
wanted to travel to the US almost half
showed their hand
having Karla has a cousin who went and
hasn't been heard from since when
consejos area I'm no closer okay she
told me children here should get an
education and a visa before leaving for
the US for all the warnings and local
pride here the march north continues the
buses are filling up the u.s. is telling
them not to come the fewer listening
Gregg Milam Sky News Guatemala